welcome to a big stomach my only model
of one at least that red thing flopping
around is actually unfolding itself it's
made out of dried pig intestine which is
pretty darn meta if you ask me
MIT researchers developed it because a
whole lot of kids swallow batteries each
year the idea is to freeze the gizmo and
feed it to the patient once it hits the
stomach the origami instrument will thaw
and unfold then the device can stick to
the offending battery with a magnet and
remove it from the digestive system
theoretically but dr. could use magnetic
fields to steer the thing theoretically
if you want to be the first person to
test it be my guest
think robots that move around the
digestive system on their own retrieving
batteries or even treating maladies
that's the wonderful thing about the
young field of Robotics seemingly
ridiculous gizmos like origami
ingestible z' and barely functional
humanoids like this may serve a real
purpose one day because if anybody's
going to swallow a battery it's going to
be a barely functional humanoid I mean
come on